he's the New York Times bestselling
author he's won a couple of Pulitzer
Prizes and he wrote when pride still
mattered life of Vince Lombardi David
Maraniss David thanks for joining us I'm
sure he's being called by a lot of
people as you remember Bart Starr and
like you were the first guy I thought of
when I heard that he passed I thought
that you would have some stories to
enlighten the audience on just who and
what Bart Starr was all about good
morning how are you
good morning Darren thanks for calling I
actually happened to be in Wisconsin on
book tour and this whole state seems to
be in mourning it's like all Packer
flags are at half mast
but yeah memories of Bart Starr are
pretty deep here you know red fire is
kind of a phenomenon and and Aaron
Rodgers is brilliant and the old glory
years Packers from Taylor and Horning
all had their special moments but really
Bart Starr is kind of a foundational
legend of this team along with Vince
Lombardi I would say but you also had a
couple of characters on there that you
know Lombardi being the disciplinarian
and then you had Horning and you know
the wide receivers like to get after it
a little bit and I'm sure some other
guys but Bart Starr just felt like he
was the right guy at the right place for
the right coach how do you explain Starr
to somebody who never saw him you know
he was on the Packers for three years
before Lombardi got there but you're
absolutely right they were a perfect
match you know some people would say
that Lombardi made star but star also
made Lombardi it was as though you know
they opened up Bart Starr's brain and
poured all of my body's knowledge into
it and he he knew how to handle that
there was a moment early in his reign
with Lombardi when when he threw an
interception and Vince just chewed him
out like he chewed out everybody else in
front of the whole team and Bart
afterwards asked to meet with Lombardi
privately and said coach you know you
want me to be your leader if I'm going
to be the leader of the team you can't
do that in public I'll take whatever you
want in private but don't ever do it in
public again and any Packer you will
talk to him from those years would say
that the star was the ultimate leader
I also mentioned there are certain
quarterbacks who benefited from winning
a Super Bowl I don't know if bard star
makes it to the Hall of Fame if he
doesn't win those first two because it's
it's a different coronation what do you
think of that
well he went five championships in seven
years young but I don't but the super
bowl designation it's branding with
these sports writers as opposed to you
know if Frank Ryan won titles with the
Cleveland Browns nobody's going Frank
Ryan deserves to be a Hall of Famer oh
you're absolutely right and people
forget two things about the first of all
the first Super Bowl wasn't even called
the Super Bowl secondly it didn't even
have you know a full stadium but the
third and most important is there was
enormous pressure on the Packers to win
that game and Lombardi put all of that
pressure onto Bart Starr who carried it
very coolly and was the MVP for the
first two Super Bowls yeah and the fact
that Starr was able to call his own
place I believe is that is that true
it's absolutely true well that they did
joke on the Packers which was a true
joke I mean it was true was that
Lombardi was the greatest coach Monday
through Saturday and was ethically
useless on the field on Sunday you know
you'd see him yelling grab grab grab get
anybody tackle out there and stuff like
that but basically Starr was the
offensive coach during the games he
called all the plays including that of
course iconic final quarterback sneak in
the ice bowl with that call I mean I you
know he's just saying I guess he says
this is the play we're gonna call
quarterback sneak I didn't have you know
nobody has great footing here and then I
think Lombardi says all right call it
and let's get out of here let's get the
hell out of here but not only that dad
but it wasn't even in the playbook there
was no quarterback speak for the Packers
and chuck was seeing the full-back
thought he was getting the ball it was
only really star and Jerry Kramer who
knew what the play was oh really yes the
rest of the team didn't know they said
you see mersin you know going up lies oh
he's going to take the handoff and score
the touchdown
so it was it was not even in the
playbook
so just Jerry Kramer who was the the
guard who was going to be making the
block so he was going to follow Kramer
and Kramer and Starr the only two that
knew this yes and you know one of the
other hidden truths of that moment is
that Ken Bowman actually liked to it
gets no credit for it but but yeah it
was it was just the two of them in it it
also showed something else about star
which was he was gutsy you know he he's
known as sort of just a a game manager
but that wasn't him at all I mean he he
was known for his going for the bomb on
fourth and one and that but I that
quarterback sneak was sort of
representative of that part of him as
well I don't know if he got lost in
Unitas his shadow and the name it came
onto the scene and Lenny Dawson was
awesome back then but was was star
competitive that way did he did he care
about recognition well are you cared
about winning
he was much tougher than people think he
had a softer meaner but he you know he
played hurt all the time he played with
his mouth bleeding for an entire quarter
and he cared deeply about winning he I
can't say that he cared as much about
the being rated versus the other
quarterbacks he'd leave that to others
and you know he wasn't charismatic I
accept
among his teammates which is what counts
in football if you decide to write
another book on a sports figure or team
what would you write it on earth are you
thinking about that you know it has to
have a larger sociological significance
for me so Clemente was the first great
Latin player and heroic humanitarian
Lombardi sort of was the symbol of
competition and success in American life
I think the one that interests me the
most but he doesn't want anybody writing
about him right now is Steve Kerr I
think he's a phenomenal story both his
life story and his Mis coaching why
doesn't he want anybody to dive in big I
think it's he just doesn't want the
distraction for his team you know maybe
when he's retired it'll be different but
not right now
yeah and he's gonna go into the Hall of
Fame with what he's done with Golden
State and you know being a role player
pretty much his entire career even at
Arizona and then I think he got cut a
few times he latches on with the Bulls
hits a big jumper with Michael wins the
championship and then we thought he was
gonna go Cote member he was gonna go and
coach the Knicks because you can't turn
down Phil Jackson and the MiGs and next
you find out he good weight he's going
to Golden State and then he's he's old
what a lot of his didn't see that shows
how smart he is and he's one smart guy
and also with what happened to his
father you know when he was assassinated
in Beirut the American University and
his you know his awareness of the world
around him I think you know one of the
things I look for especially if someone
I'm writing about is is still alive is
their ability to go deeper and he
definitely count on a lot of subjects
this Gregg Popovich interest you yes he
does - absolutely those are the two I
would say you know what if you like wine
and you get a couple of bottles of wine
then I'm gonna guess pop would open up
to you but probably when both of them
are done and you know Kerr working with
Popovich is interesting - oh absolutely
no the two of them are from the same
mold David thank you I know you're busy
and traveling safe travels and thank you
for joining us great to talk with you
David Maraniss a New York Times best
seller and he wrote the book when pride
still mattered a life of Vince Lombardi
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]